كان في البدايه من مؤسسي شركات الذكاء
الاصطناعي ثم تحول بشكل مفاجئ الى عدو لها
يدعو لايقاف تطوير هذه التقنيه والان يدعو
الى التنافس في هذا القطاع نتحدث هنا طبعا
عن ايلون ماسك الذي شدد على ضروره وحاجه
انشاء شركه ذكاء الصناعي لمنافسه جوجل
ومايكروسوفت يمكن ان تشمل اجزاء مختلفه من
امبراطوريه شركته بما في ذلك موقع تويتر
هذا هو ادنى ماسك بهذه التعليقات خلال قمه
مجلس الرؤساء التنفيذيين لصحيفه
واقترح ماسك بحسب الصحيفه ان يكون تويتر
جزءا من جهوده لانشاء شركه ذكاء صناعي
وقال ان تويتر وتسلا يمكن ان يكون شريكين
مع شركه ذكاء اصطناعي بحسب الصحيفه التي
اشارت الى ان ماسك انشا شركه ذكاء الصناعي
تسمى اكس اي اي وقلم ماسك اعتقد انه يجب
ان يكون هناك حصان ثالث مهم في هذا السباق
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات